[Musique]
alors on salue la planète sur la seule
caméra qui fonctionne encore ici qu'en
studio prendre la perte du 2e tient une
seconde qui reviendra mais une chose est
sûre c'est qu'on ait cinq ici pour
vendre beaucoup de plaisir ensemble pour
parler de choses de la vie quotidienne
des canadiens
c'est un thème canada en direct de moria
lillers 11h11
vendredi 25 janvier 24 janvier 25 24 qui
compte on vérifie suis encore debout
vous réveiller alors au tour de table
d'abord aller sans talent d'un homme qui
a accepté à la dernière minute de se
joindre l'émission bonjour chantal
bonjour stéphane c'est toujours un
plaisir d'être avec vous c'est un
extrait main c'est une belle chose allez
voir on va parler de tradition
aujourd'hui et j'espère vous allez nous
aider à cuisiner pour la cuisine je suis
pas très bonne là dedans mais je vais me
débrouiller
question finances marie jobin vous
cuisinez une fois de temps en temps oui
oui mais je dois dire que lorsqu'on
travaille à temps plein c'est pas
évident de trouver le temps vous auriez
besoin d'une aide ménagère maintenant
les clauses si souvent que ça m'aide pas
ménagères mais edge web
aussi cette émission fantastique les
deux caméras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors léo jimena au fait merci beaucoup
d'être gentil démission aujourd'hui
merci alors on devine le thème démission
aujourd'hui savez comment ça fonctionne
une image qui vaut mille mots bien ça
devient une vidéo bien sûr
et voici donc cette vidéo ça qui marche
en cinq images devenues le thème de
cette émission les gens au bureau ou à
la maison vous jouez avec nos premières
images ça c'est de la malbouffe
marthe quoi le nouveau guide alimentaire
voilà ça pourrait être ça ne s'est pas
ça non elle aggrave bacon ceux du
véhicule mais c'est pas le sujet des
missions dur et ça c'est assez d'helaba
bête
moi je connais un barbecue oui la viande
dans l'alimentation les viandes canadien
puis elle a parlé du gué des martyrs
canadiens dont on a connu des vies table
couleurs cette semaine
première fois depuis 2009 qui avait fait
en 2007
mais des spécialistes ici un studio on
aura un invité dans quelques instants
sur ce cas qui lui le grand spécialiste
canadien du côté francophone dans ce
genre de questions alimentaires alors
des rodez bat ensemble de cette guerre
contre les carnivores de cette guerre
contre les les
l'hélium les bouchers et contre la
viande il ya une véritable campagne
menée étude après étude de publier on
dirait à toutes les semaines tous les
mois
et ça depuis 2015 environ on sent que la
pression s'est pas seulement pour le
bien-être de la personne ne sait aussi
pour le bien-être de la planète de
l'environnement tout en est le bien-être
des animaux
c'est en fait c'est le bien-être à mort
parce que
quand mais il vend pas beaucoup de
viande les prix est en train de ces
salles or moi je suis très content vous
allez à manger davantage malgré la
campagne mondiale contre la viande
géographe de campagne contre la violence
puis les gens ils continuent à faire
quelque chose lui la santé est bonne
quand même
il va mourir jeune beau et en santé mais
je trouve ça intéressant parce que ce
qui se passe en studio en ce moment
c'est exactement ce qui se passe chez
tous les to les jambes dans la planète
qu'est ce qu'on peut manger qu'on doit
pas manger les fruits et légumes les
primes ont augmenté tout ce qui touche
le soya ça va augmenter
donc il va peut-être avoir un
rééquilibrage côté marché chez les
consommateurs en plus l'histoire c'est
très facile et manger santé c'est cher
faire ça je vous ai posé toutes les
questions tantôt parce que j'ai regardé
un peu la une du guide alimentaire du
nouveau guide alimentaire dans le plat
on a comme une toute petite portion de
viande et de poisson qui enfin ces deux
aliments qui font désormais partie du
groupe des actes une hyper protéiné donc
du coup leur portion est réduite à une
portion congrue dans l'assiette
stéphane a déjà des questions alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici là sur la table
notre invité à temps de faire un test
mais on peut l'appeler tout simplement
au moment de votre juron d'un mieux mais
nous c'est que ça c'est pas comme un
avion peut décoller des travers bien sûr
alors premier tour de l'ain grosse boule
20 points à perdre
il y en a 100 points à perdre au total à
chaque émission trois tours de la grosse
boule premier tour sa porte justement
sur ces portions réduites devient dans
notre alimentation non seulement suggéré
par le guide alimentaire canadien cette
semaine mais aussi un peu partout autour
de la planète
alors voici selon un rapport publié il
ya à peine quelques jours paris tu as
mangé un groupe d'experts en nutrition
indépendant bazin stars comme qui a
publié dans la revue médicale 27 son
enquête
quelle est la quantité maximale de
viande rouge que nous devrions manger
pour notre santé et celle de
ah vous avez un choix on guide ici vous
avez à heimberg heures par mois b un
burger par semaine ou c aucune de ces
réponses
moi j'irai avec des imberts garde par
semaine ça coûte pas cher chez vous
allez me chez mc dardon d'une fois par
semaine seulement bon mais on peut le
faire à la maison
ah c'est vrai ces raisons mais vous
cuisinez pas souvent vacances c'est
facile c'est vrai père semaine ce serait
donc b dans votre cas mais au fil de sa
réponse si je m'en tiens aux
recommandations de santé canada cette
semaine à savoir qu'il faut mettre
l'accent sur les graines et les légumes
secs
j'irai avec un par mois 1 par mois une
chance n'avait pas écrit mme guigou
je suis destiné à karni va alors des
deux côtés ici au milieu c'est la viande
vous avez gagné vous avez remporté la
bonnerie semaines mais ça le prophète
faire quand même pas de hamburgers à
papa d'un beau morceau de stijl le style
c'est un poste qui complètement 1 ça
c'est sûr c'est à proscrire
oui c'est tout nouveau sa pensée il ya
beaucoup de canadiens qui disent non la
viande
officiellement pour toujours mais on y
voit tricher pendant pas vrai avec notre
spécialiste de l'alimentaire rendement
des maris jobin de le présenter puisque
elle lui parle très souvent c'est le
spécialiste canadien du secteur par jour
- ou plan francophones de ces questions
là j'ai besoin des jeux si j'ai toutes
ses coordonnées
je connais par coeur sans titre bloquer
tous ses crimes comme une bonne vieille
recette pour vous il est avec nous on va
voir s'il nous entend
moi j'adore alors on entende on le voit
pas encore alors ça monsieur charlebois
vous êtes là vous entendez oui vous voir
ici
oui parce qu'on a garde bien oui oui oui
c'est super
je vois cinq personnes ce qu'elle en
al'air en santé savoir parce que bon
c'est parce qu'on se parle à l'occasion
sylvain charlebois
il est professeur en distribution et
politique agroalimentaire à l'université
dalhousie
ça c'était halifax sur la côte est du
canada
donc c'est en nouvelle écosse pour ceux
qui exactement parfait on est bien situé
professeur vous même vous avez mis la
main à pâte
il ya quelques temps vous avez publié
une enquête vous avez sonder les
canadiens puissamment si c'était au fond
en train de laisser de côté la viande
pour devenir des végétariens végétaliens
lien puis il ya d'autres gros mots qui
sont sortis de votre enquête il ya des
conclusions quand même assez étonnante
au niveau de la consommation de viande
de protéines da par des canadiens c'est
quoi les aider les grandes manchettes
pour vous d'abord via de plus en plus de
vega nhs et de végétariens au canada en
fête
liot de plus en plus de l'ex italie
ici on met tout le monde dans le même
panier l'on parle de 6.4 millions de
canadiens qui soit ont décidé d'éliminer
la viande de lord y est ou qui ont des
de limiter la viande dans l'or dans leur
dit de façon générale alors on voit
qu'il ya vraiment une progression sur
118 % de ces gens là on 38 ans ou moins
donc on voit que là les deux jeunes
générations les mille et nous la
génération oz s'intéresse
particulièrement à une diète sans viande
ou avec moins de viande et nous on a
l'impression que il va y avoir de plus
en plus de gens qui vont faire ceux
d'ailleurs ce qu'on s'est aperçu qu'elle
avait depuis quelques semaines c'est
qu'il ya un manque de tofu c'est pas
normal au mois de janvier de manquer de
tofu mais ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que
ils risquent de marquer du theux fut
pendant quelques mois ce qui skie
inusité on voit vraiment que au delà des
réseaux
deux nouvelles années je veux changer de
dictature j'ai l'impression que de plus
en plus de gens s'adonnent à une autre
genre de dieppe 500 viance en protéines
animales donc pénurie de tofu comme
pénurie de marijuana spatiale maryse
j'avais une question oui parce que quand
il ya pénurie augmentations de prix un
sévère sur le bois c'est ce qu'on voit
là ben ccsa exactement alors j'ai liang
ou mans pour la protéine végétale de
façon générale le tofu ce qui est
particulier c'est que c'est un produit
qui sur le marché depuis fort longtemps
qui bien connu qui s'adapte bien qui est
flexible on peut faire toutes sortes de
choses avec le tofu alors c'est une once
une protéine végétale familière pour
beaucoup de monde même ceux qui sont de
forts carnivores le qui aime beaucoup la
viande mais veulent laisser tenter par
d'autres genres de diète messieurs
charlebois je vais vous poser une
question qui a trait à la santé
je sais que vous n'êtes pas médecin mais
je veux quand même savoir est-ce qu'on
peut décider comme ça de se passer
totalement de la viande sans observer
une certaine incidence sur notre santé
une bonne question
c'est ce que j'veux pas au médecin ou
nutritionnistes diététiciens mais ce qui
arrive par contre c'est que les gens ont
de plus en plus accès à de l'information
il ya vingt ans trente heures c'était
une unité de 2 d'élever des enfants
vegan par exemple ou végétariens c'était
même perçu comme étant irresponsable
aujourd'hui vous savez au canada des
quatre livres des limitations qui se
vendent le plus
gare de troyes qui sont liées à l'
organisme et il ya un de ces quatre
livres qui est écrit pour les parents
qui veulent élever leurs enfants vegan
alors il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'informations
qui en fait que les consommateurs
peuvent lire et se sentent en fait en
position de prendre des décisions aussi
radicale que change de diète ou changer
la diète de leur art dans notre enquête
on dit que 40 % des canadiens ne mangent
de la viande qu'une à deux fois
seulement par semaine moi je dois avouer
que c'est pas vraiment pour des
considérations de santé uniquement mais
pour des considérations de prix qui
vient environ 2 ou 3 lorsque l'épée du
boeuf était dans la stratosphère j'ai
dit bon bah je mangeais avec du porc et
puis bon on va diminuer les portions à
manger plus de ris parce que ça coûte
très cher maintenant jusqu'à quel point
les canadiens sont d'abord sensible aux
fluctuations de prix septet éléments qui
a lancé cette mode est ce que ça va se
poursuivre chez que ça coûte cher de
produire de la viande mais quand même
monnaie je sais que les prix ont diminué
un peu là depuis cinq six mois
moi j'achète un peu plus de viande ouais
c'est un bon point 2014 a été une année
charnière pour la viande surtout pour le
boeuf les prix le prix du boeuf avait
augmenté de 25% quelques mois et c'est
vraiment alors à mon avis que les gens
se sont aussi intéressés à d'autres
sources de protéines ont commencé à
regarder davantage le porc le poulet
d'ailleurs le poulet
la dame entre le poulet par capteur est
en hausse depuis quelques temps en
raison de sa mais aussi à des gens
qu'ils se sont intéressés à la porte et
le végétal aussi 2004 depuis 2004 ans ça
va extrêmement mal pour le boeuf et
c'est pour ça que cette année pour la
première fois avec notre apport
alimentaire le rapport sur les prix
alimentaires
on anticipe une baisse de prix pour la
viande et c'est principalement en raison
du boeuf alors vous avez tout à fait
raison
le prix du boeuf stagne ou est en baisse
à travers le pays je suis content je
viens de l'argentine à la racine on
mange j'ai vu un documentaire ça fait
pas longtemps puis c'est à peu près 75
kg de viande par année par personne de
viande de boeuf
alors notre culture c'est loin des
matisse mais j'aime la viande rouge et
pichet une femme ma question c'était
surtout pour les enfants est ce que
c'est vrai que si on évite de donner des
débiteurs protéines animales aux enfants
et ailleurs un changement dans la façon
dont les enfants ils peuvent jeu pour
grandir aujourd'hui franchement je ne
sais pas vraiment une question qu'on
devrait poser un médecin mais janvier
réponse de plus tôt il ya tellement
d'informations bonne ou mauvaise sur
internet dans des livres vous allez vous
allez dans une bibliothèque ou une
librairie vous allez voir que tellement
d'informations sur la diète vegan la dj
taille
les gens se sentent en fait plus
confiante en plus à l'aise de prendre
des décisions aussi importantes que ça
il y avait un test à pau du tout le col
c'était parti c'était en fait le mauvais
gars là on entendait pratiquement jamais
parlé aujourd'hui le terme vegan les
vegan en fait la diète intime
socialement normalisées depuis les tous
derniers mois sur le mail les élever
c'était sur star trek c'est sûr on va
revenir au guide alimentaire canadien
parce que j'ai eu une bonne conversation
avec lui plus tôt cette semaine marie
mais en fait oui parce que on posait la
question pire c'est que les gens disent
on va manger des noix mais les noix ou
ici en effet très important sur
l'environnement
il ya des endroits californie où il n'y
a pas assez d'eau ces problématiques
alors si tout le monde sur la terre se
met à manger des noix est ce qu'on aura
des crises où il repassait doute pour en
produire et que la votre 100 g ou 200 g
de noix coûtera aussi cher sinon plus
cher que de la viande pour avoir le bon
rapport de protéines qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
ces vins bariseau tout à fait raison en
fait il va falloir l'attention en fait
est vraiment sur la protéine animale
ce qui est un peu disproportionné on
parle de noix mais moi je vois parler
aussi de fruits et légumes
vous savez on n'est pas pour des
milliards de dollars de fruits et
légumes de partout et là depuis 7
semaines santé canada demande aux
canadiens ou en fait pression gaz et de
deux que de consommer plus de fruits et
légumes la moitié de l'assiette du guide
alimentaire cd faisait des gains le
transport la logistique derrière tout ça
c'est incroyable donc c'est pas dur à
baisser mais c'est pour ça que a
d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré la ministre de
la santé hier et je lui ai dit va
falloir penser sérieusement à augmenter
de cap à ces pollutions niveau horticole
parce que ces six ça peut pas c'est pas
durable on pointe du doigt
à mon avis
de façon injuste la protéine animale
alors qu'il ya d'autres problèmes liés à
l'environnement ailleurs dans la tasse y
est vous avez vu le prix des poivrons
rouges en magasin c'est un prix qui a
explosé littéralement j'en achetais 4 et
là j'en achète un pour résumer de la
viande quelques fois par semaine puis
bien à traiter sans trop de gras c'est
bon pour la santé
non il a dit la ministre
non parce qu'il ya quand même vraiment
la viande a mauvaise réputation mais on
dirait qu'il faut suivre cette mauvaise
réputation
est-ce que c'était pas aussi un effort
de l'industrie derrière les noirs
derrière les frais légumes pour nous
c'est parce que pendant longtemps on a
dit que et vivent pensent que monsieur
charbonneau pourra confirmer
on a dit que le lobby laitier et les
viandes étaient derrière le nouveau
guide alimentaire canadien
mais j'ai réalisé une entrevue que
monsieur charles barrière et on nous dit
qu'avec homme d'un nouveau billet
alimentaire on a par là déjà que t'es
pas mal d'un côté de le représenter
seulement un côté de la médaille est-ce
que c'est comme si charleroi
ben c'est un peu ça on dit qu'il est
leur but on était petit côté pour le
nouveau guide mais lieu mois de la façon
je le vois c'est que yo larbi que quand
même remporté la partie 2 essais de
l'aube et des nutritionnistes et des
diététistes et puis ce sont des gens
extrêmement compétents mais ils ont une
vision très restreint de l'alimentation
extrêmement restreint même je pourrais
même dire peut-être un peu élitiste qui
hors de la portée de la majorité des cas
d'hier j'ai visité une banque
alimentaire à montréal et puis
le guide alimentaire en fait et s'est
éloigné de la masse cette semaine moi je
suis préoccupé par la sécurité
alimentaire et ge procu par la façon que
le gréement terre se lie avec la
population canadienne
moi ce que j'aurais aimé voir je les dis
allah mainitien ses devoirs des
sociologues des historiens des
économistes est impliqué dans le
processus pour dix ont incité le débat
et les déchets change d'idée ce qu'un
jour j'ai vu ce qu'on voit dans le
rapport dans le guide ses treize
personnes qui pensent pareil qui lui qui
en fait qui partagent les mêmes bases
théoriques et intellectuelles et j'ai
l'impression que pas eu trop de des bols
durant le procès les personnes qui ont
des revenus également supérieure à la
moyen parce que c'est des gens qui sont
dans l'ensemble de l'arrêt plus bon ben
c'est pas le salaire moyen déjà
exactement ces délits 13 sont des
preuves professeur chercheur privilégié
de la vie j'en suis un
je lève où je suis chanceux mais parfois
le il faut peut-être de offrir le qui
connaissent la misère c'est quoi la
misère puis comme on peut les aider pour
s'en sortir
dernière question monsieur charles mois
en attendant donc le grand débat
participatif qui devrait permettre à
toutes les parties prenantes de se
prononcer sur la meilleure manière de
manger en tant que prophète je me pose
des questions comment est ce que je
devrais continuer à m'alimenter
normalement et sainement selon vous moi
j'ai toujours truc c'est un choix
personnel le guide alimentaire 7
c'est une ressource évidemment c'est une
ressource et c'est une politique qui est
très important pour le pour le pays mais
c'est une ressource c'est à vous parce
que j'ai trouvé dans le guide c'est que
on est assis prescriptive dans la proche
on laisse pas les les cultures
culinaires émerger on dirait qu'on
manque un peu de respect pour nos
traditions gastronomiques et puis on a
un peuple assez multiculturelle au
canada il ya des gens qui arrivent de
partout dans le monde ailleurs d un
héritage alimentaire qui est tout à fait
différent et à mon avis faut le
respecter
pis dans le guide alimentaire il ya pas
beaucoup de choses nature merci beaucoup
professeur de vous être joints à nous je
vous êtes à quelque part à montréal où
vous êtes merci à air canada où west jet
peu importe la compagnie sinon on en a
pas plus parlé merci beaucoup professeur
alors c'était le professeur sylvain
charlebois 2 on est fixé
je connais sur notre planète notre
chronique on dit d autres articles qui
accompagne cette émission dans laquelle
on peut poursuivre la conversation à
tête reposée une fois que l'émission
vous l'avez regardé vous pouvez
continuer à écouter nos entrevues
reportages sur ces questions portant sur
le boeuf et le combat contre le boeuf
voyez j'en ai une
en haut la cyberguerre en fait d'une
compagnie qu'ils appellent ça le bug
mpasse bon c'est la deuxième version est
apparemment cette goutte comme la vraie
bien bon et puis là donc veiller des
articles récents notre avec sylvain
justement sur l'étude dont vous parliez
des faits hier et puis il ya d'autres
documents donc le combat contre la
viande depuis 2015 à notre antenne ou à
l'antenne de radio canada international
oui et moi je fais des chroniques un
espagnol laine de la technologie pour le
service espagnol puis ça fait deux trois
mois je fais une chronique de messieurs
italien qui habite en espagne qui est
enfin en train de bâtir en fait
imprimantes ray 3d que on ajoute des
éléments végétale puis on peut faire des
espèces des mystiques qui lia est arrivé
à voir la texture est ce qu'ils les
gunnes légaux des la viande mais ça se
fait aussi déjà en france mais le gars
j'ai parlé avec lui puis magique et les
problèmes c'est que si on change tout
l'addition la production de viande vers
les ressources y en a pas il y en a pas
pour changer au complet ou basculer
total progressif pis il faut mélanger
c'est ça vous pensent des générations
avant de tout chambarder exacte et la
question si c'est que si on n'utilise
plus d'outils électroniques pour
produire la viande est ce que ça pas un
impact aussi environnemental
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les outils
électroniques lorsqu'ils ne sont plus
bons tandis que avec le jeu c'est pas le
purin par ou encore ce que les vaches
encore exactement ce qui sort par en
arrière on peut le réutiliser
alors il ya besoin de facteurs c'est
très connu une recherche google mais un
fonctionnement des milliers d
ordinateurs qui produisent de la chaleur
alors ça c'est aussi la contamination
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on arrêtait
l'internet
non on continue dans cette deuxième tour
de la grosse boule
combien de points internes pour le
deuxième tour d'habitude c'est quoi 40
non c'est non je n'ai perdu déjà 20 moi
aussi j'ai peur qu'une y en a
vous avez tous en boule
déjà avec le purin alors aussi deuxième
tour de la grosse boule 30 points à
perdre 7,1 pour cent des canadiens se
disent végétarien d'accord alors que
dieu quand même si 7,1 pâques
d'après les études du grand professeur
qui est passé ici la kippa mais froide
accor 2 3% ceux des livres comme étant
végétalien d'azur qui mangent les
végétaux et sans viande
c'est ce que c'est ça que ça veut dire
non c'est à dire le défi italien c'est
qu'ils mangent même pas du gain mais pas
de lait d'origine animale très bien quel
pourcentage des canadiennes ne sont pas
des végétariens ou des végétaliens mais
bien des flexitariens il en a parlé donc
oui oui je sais pas c'est un flex italie
vous écoutiez pas j'ai pris en compte
aussi quatre millions de canadiens sont
des végétariens et des végétariens mais
les fluxs italien non non j'ai pas su
les flexitariens c'est des végétariens
qui mangent ou occasionnellement de la
viande du poisson il triche à la
complexité 7% végétarien 17,1 pour cent
des canadiens sont végétariens 2 3 % se
disent comme étant un des jeux
d'alliances en plus du tournoi mais il
ya des gens qui sont luxe de rien on les
dit attendez un peu il ya le choix des
pourcentages
je guide aucune de ces réponses cc
aucune de ces réponses ou encore à trois
pour cent des canadiens sondés
flexitariens ou encore dix pour cent des
canadiens sa cb sondés flexitariens peu
lourde à temps pour voir qui moi aussi
j'avais connaissez même pas je vois de
réponse il n'a pas d'adressé et à
commencer par ça aucune des ces réponses
aux nôtres trois pour cent des canadiens
sondés flexitariens 10 % des canadiens
sur dix ans trois mâts ça va être bon ça
moi je dis c'est 3 3% bonnes réponses
alors je retrouve mes 20 mai 20 points
vous n'avez pas perdu votre emploi vous
avez 4e qui avait répondu quelque chose
ne répondent quelque chose dans cinq ans
on a perdu confiance et ailleurs c'est
donc soixante dix alors quand vous avez
80 points soit 70 points et 5 ans
souvenez vous de ça pour le troisième
jeu voici troisième tour de la grosse
boule saint père louis mavericks pas
trop sa visite parce que le temps file
qui alors aussi à quel pourcentage de
toute la nourriture produite au canada
est perdu gâtés à avant d'être consommée
ou jetés après avoir été cuisiné par
maryse commence à cuisiner par mois
selon l'organisation qui a fait le
gaspillage réponse je crois mais
j'espère que votre réponse tanguay choix
de réponses
bonjour écoutez moi je n'ai pas
d'objection que quelques pourcents
ajouter 60 selon cette organisation
locke a fait les frais des chiffres
d'années me bouger à 18 pour cent de
tous les aliments qui finissent par se
retrouver les jumelles sont produits au
canada attention qui serait venu par
exemple de californie n'ont produit
aucun à produire qu'on attend
distinction importante la paix 38 % de
tous les aliments produits au canada
consommée par les canadiens sont jetés à
la poubelle ou c c 58 pour sa fille
appât aucun de ces réponses n'ont pas
dit non mais moi la question c'est
est-ce que la réponse que vous avez en
tête et dans ses choix et moi j'avais 60
% en tête mais on peut dans cinq ans
tuée tout cela c'est 60% de l'ensemble
de la nourriture produits les officiels
qui vient d'ailleurs d'annoncer de canal
au canada les produits au canada ça veut
pas dire que ça pousse et au canada non
mais si elle avait 60 % à 58 tout ça on
est crucial on a beau aimer à 58% on
serait proche de l'argoat
celle ci je sais tu as le bon chiffre on
va peut-être les choix vous répondez
ensuite votre avis qu'est ce que vous
dites moi mon objectif c'est pas tout
les points là à ok assez combien assez
combien discute ça c'est beaucoup trop
fait était bonne élève
sinon on parlera alors de gaspillage
alimentaire 18% ca pour lui et ses 5 ans
tu pour ça c'est ce qui se rapproche le
plus de la réponse lui mais 60%
si on parle de gaspillage alimentaire il
se pourrait samsung vend ma d'elvis
mais j'irai quand même avec 38% sur les
lieux juste moi moi moi mais je pense
que je vais aller avec
je suis ma collègue ici la madone c'est
quoi ça 58 58 64 ans avait 10 58% des
les bonnes réponses
les trois sages alors c'est quoi le taux
le score total à 170 nous ne tenions mes
parts on a eu des points là non vous
n'avez pas perdu de points d'accord on
est à 70 semaines elle est toujours ah
non là perdu j'avais acheté à 80g j'en
ai perdu le 50/50 non pas 100 de gce de
la plongée au coeur du nouveau préfet
des citations
merci merci n'a pas quoi d'un jour et dû
me fier à marie-claude moi ça m'a marqué
ça veut dire l organisme ce spécialiste
d'art et essayer de récupérer le plus
possible d'aller en finale
mais ça ça démontre quelque chose
premièrement lorsqu'on va faire l'ex
crise qu'on féministe dans notre liste
est ce qu'on prévoit ce qu'on va manger
ou cuisiner je cuisine muscles usine
près st trop souvent mais je m'excuse
mais après de la semaine à manille en a
moins
mais on fait avec ce qu'ils y restent
mais ça ça me viennent ma mère parce
qu'à l'époque les gens avaient des
budgets on se fait un budget pour les
français pas les particuliers c'est
peut-être les industries mais juste
mettre un bémol là dessus c'est que
quand on parle de la nourriture qui se
retrouve un peu comme aux déchets ces
contraintes ont aussi des departed
animal quand on se servira jamais comme
ddo la chèvre
du poulet qu'on veut pas cuisiner avec
le poulet donc beaucoup de déchets qui
accompagnent par exemple certains fruits
comme les anars c'est quoi la portion de
la nana qui finit à la poubelle c'est
bien plus que 50% des ja de couper les
cornes alors bon coup mais ce que c'est
cette d'échelle à son compte et ses
chiffres écoutez voici l'anc est -ce qui
a fait enquête
est ce une étude ou une enquête voici
mon petit côté scientifique l'acquis qui
ressort et qui me dérange c'est une
étude que les chercheurs qualifient de
premières mondiales en son genre
donc c'est une étude chercher première
en son genre de débilité de l'entité qui
a mené cette étude et de cette émission
qui sont fait l'écho 1
bien sûr je sais que vous avez à la
critique moi j'aimerais vous montrer une
image à ce que je peux faire ça c'est
faites ce que vous voulez parce que
c'est le vin est notre charlebois
parlait justement que les guides est un
peu élitiste et ça que j'ai finale de
voir là la caricature de garnotte qu'est
ce que c'est totalement perdu ouais
fermer la gare décrit des tomates
qu'est-ce que ça kg 60 affiches
originales ça dit aidez moi à manger
mais ça a été corrigé par lui-même
j'imagine ça dit aidez moi à suivre le
guide alimentaire canadien
bonne chance cela corrobore très bien ce
que disait monsieur charlebois tente où
nous sommes maintenant prêts pour la
devinette deviner l'image de la semaine
et voici maestro merci astic alors c'est
un thème de musique plein de suspense je
vous rappelle la règle du jeu
y'a rien à gagner mais vous devez me
poser des questions auxquelles je ne
peux répondre que par oui ou par non au
bout d'un petit talisman de la semaine
quelle est l'image de la semaine est-ce
que ça va est-ce que ça reparte sur un
événement au canada ça implique le
canada ce qui se passe aux etats unis
non ça se passe à ne rien non ça se
passe en amérique latine oui la
connaissance de du président
autoproclamé qui a enquillé reconnu un
président autoproclamé qui a fait ça
c'est le premier ministre du canada
entre autres et les états unis et toutes
les nations sont sinon c'est pas tout
mais beaucoup de la plupart il ya eu des
exceptions notables brisé je pense
qu'ils ont décidé de pas faire ça ne pas
faire ça la russie a aussi et puis la
chine
celui qui était à davos représente
l'image la semaine c'est la vidéo parce
que c'est bien c'est numéro 2 je pense
les manifestations vont au delà d'une
certaine hystérie lac accompagnent quand
même le mouvement de contestation est ce
que vous savez combien césar à deux
millions de ces couacs comment s'appelle
la devise dans ce pays on et 90 millions
fausse paru en amont non non non la de
la devise s'apprécie mignon de cette
devise pour un dollar et devises
monétaires alors vous imaginez à
tellement de gens et c'est vraiment une
crise alors ça pour moi c'est une crise
politique
et puis c'est pas réglé il ya deux
présidents maintenant voilà un président
autoproclamé
ça commence à faire un bout de temps
qu'il ya des images marquantes qui ne
viennent pour en faire un thème la
semaine prochaine si jamais les choses
s'y prête on verra mais entre temps il
faudrait remercie infiniment aller ce
chantage tandem c'est mon tour merci de
l'invitation à la dernière minute ont
accepté de venir comme une brique dans
la mare c'est sous juillet
c'est toujours un plaisir de participer
à l'émission stéphane s'est beaucoup
impliqué maryse merci de vous être
présentées vous êtes fait une chute
comme des milliers de canadiens cette
semaine au genou éraflé ce que mal au
poignet gauche et puis bon mais ça va ça
va passer il a toute sa tête encore et
puis plus important marie-claude vous
n'êtes rien arriver mais a mis du temps
en autos a devancé des tempêtes ou
problème dans la circulation cette
semaine avec la neige et le verglas est
en fait un bouquet d cour d'appel saisie
de données sur la route c'est vrai
zigonet gigant et on se promène on
n'avance pas beaucoup vre ouais le voyez
en bateau zigeuner en auto oui mais je
suis en train d'apprendre à patiner mais
tu métro jusqu'au travail je patine
c'est ça je vais pas trop les laisse par
dida mais je suis en train de faire
bientôt il va être recruté par les
canadiens
il faut qu'en qui mange un peu plus de
viande et abats
surtout que la viande va coûter beaucoup
moins cher mais en parlant de la viande
on a oublié
la question du mouvement de lesparre il
faut faire du sport il faut bien manger
puis il faut bien faire d'autres choses
aussi
il ya beaucoup de gens qui est qu'ils
ont des langes et d'arriver à 100 ans
et puis mangé la viande tous les jours
mais je trouve ça intéressant ce que tu
dit leonardo parce que moi le 28
décembre
je suis allé au centième anniversaire
donc le blaze qui était le frère de mon
père blaise saint tin son père était
mort à 93 ces géants l'hommage est de la
viande et de tous alors il ya aussi une
question de génétique mais sait déjà qui
bougeait alors les amène à télé ou de
magasins font monter les escaliers 25 30
fois par jour alors à cette époque là
les gens n'étaient pas installés devant
la tablette ou devant la télé les gens
bouger alors saint tin et encore très
influents comme un discours internet
alors merci beaucoup à tout le monde
puis la semaine prochaine
[Musique]